мораторій захищаючи землю адже продаж за
без тіні вище дільничного так зайняти
амура турію призначаєшся владні йому
мережа продавати свої одягай ось і може
і дали здавати їх в оренду у проекту
закону про обидві сільського саудівського
земель поневолюється поетапно зняття
мораторій у друк на державний пояс
воду ми нагрівати не дощ сіна форму в
це посту підлоги
як висвітлювати доз вигляд crying центральну
it as he дно і Європи віддаленості рук і
артист по них проти розум перших руки і
слимаки а ми ж доросла на 20-40
сотки
мораторій захищаючи за землю та тіньового
ринку не сірий ринок землі з але й давно
ти хто хоче може вбитий мораторій
прикладом виглядає вмовивши і від
десяткову оренду обидва домовивши мвд за
suite поневолюють право на вершинах про
розставанні а його люди не ділянку і
заданим та мінюсту 2016 еротики або
кисть таких у рік доросла на 80
сотки
та за прогнозами української асоціації
аграрного бізнесу цеху ось у по точному
роті станеш чим більше а опціях
тіньового ринку вся в 2 початі мільярдів
гривень
мораторій заражаючи розвитку віагру
сектор так dia мораторій устр і моя
прибуток інвестиції питання сектор отже
орендована земля не може бути предметом
заставою так само на увазі моє реально
ринку зовсім на землі
ж розміру туре аграрний сектор в
україні монополізова ний грибним
владні com пробачиш а дати по бо
ринду валиком холдингом нішу коти кішки
на виданні держави списування муру
турі і пам'ятний тр мови води ніагару
бізнесу на ефекти мені держава
зможе продати землю
ринок землі забрати все і образу після
скошування мораторію не палять пробуну
і знімають і мораторії поетапно протягом
руки
продажів приватних за їх заміною ти
продаж право оренди
однак і законопроект he now хвалив і в
1 година щоб в Україні по мнуть сину
забрати його на ринок землі по трибун і
функцію нині і коли старе кіно хіба
заповнений малюка трахкати більше ніжно
статеве ну і з чобо земельні
закони нас у прочитав його ден одному
виставок хоча з касу ваня мораторій на
продаж землі травня по нір мови
його продовження ж на економічно ви
правда нам за барона на продаж землі
спрею та функціонування тіньового ри
такий рубці та а також заражаючи розвитку
грибного фермерство